will ferrell and john c reilly are one
of the most dynamic comedy duo's in
hollywood having previously joined
forces to split sides and Step Brothers
and Talladega Nights
The Ballad of Ricky Bobby don't you
stick that knife in your leg
but sadly Ferrell and Riley's latest
venture the Sherlock Holmes spoof Holmes
and Watson looks like a total bust
professional critics and a horde of
Twitter randos alike say the film is so
bad that some audience members are
leaving theatres before the credits roll
with some even requesting refunds
directed by Tropic Thunder & idiocracy
co-writer a Tom Cowan Holmes and Watson
opened on Christmas Day 2018 but wasn't
screened to members of the media ahead
of its wide launch once critics and fans
actually feasted their eyes upon what
ought to have been another hilarious
ferrell reilly two-hander things went
sour fast as of the making of this video
Holmes and Watson sits at a bleak 5%
critical approval rating and 26% fan
score on Rotten Tomatoes one viewer
wrote bluntly on Twitter Holmes and
Watson was the worst movie of all time
first movie I've ever walked out on
another random and rage movie goer
tweeted Holmes and Watson is an absolute
disaster had to wake up three other
family members 40 minutes and just to
walk out possibly overtakes Ishtar as
worst movie of all time don't waste your
money or time that doesn't make sense
1987 Ishtar starring Warren Beatty and
Dustin Hoffman is widely considered to
be one of the worst cinematic disasters
ever with Roger Ebert calling it at one
time quote a lifeless massive lumbering
exercise and failed comedy so not
exactly great company bailing on a flick
40 minutes in is pretty bad but it gets
worse a woman shared that she and her
boyfriend walked out of Holmes and
Watson 15 minutes in boyfriend's movie
choosing privileges are cancelled
yikes so what went wrong on paper Holmes
and Watson has everything going for it
Beryl and Riley playing goofy versions
of Arthur Conan Doyle's classic
characters a talented screenwriter
sitting in the director's seat and a
first-rate UK cast
including ray Fiennes in practice
however nothing really worked
critics have set a flame just about
every aspect of Holmes and Watson
denouncing the lazy and out-of-control
direction the unfunny script that misses
the mark as a parody and all the
heavy-handed references and jokes that
completely fall flat in his review
Newsday's Rafer Guzman described Holmes
and Watson as one of those movies that
goes beyond unfunny and into a comedy
Cuba zone where jokes are no longer
recognizable and laughter is
philosophically impossible no Marie of
the Los Angeles Times was a bit nicer
calling the film more of a well-meaning
misfire than a total train wreck
frustrating mainly because all these
folks can do much better
Murray added that many of the actors
look quote befuddled about what they're
supposed to be doing which is never a
good sign Peter sub Sinskey from Roger
Ebert calm was far more brutal in his
half star review writing Holmes and
Watson is so excruciating ly awful that
you have to wonder what it was other
than their paychecks that could have
possessed the cast and crew to keep
coming back each day when it must have
been obvious from the first day of
shooting that the project was the most
hopeless of cases imaginable so if
you're looking for a laugh the answer
appears Elementary avoid Holmes and
Watson at all costs check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]